[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this record makes me want to drive it's
like a driving record it's like it takes
you places and it there's some really
heartfelt country moments on it there's
some feisty moments there's some
and that's always what i try to do on
records i try to have a little bit of
everything but this one the whole vibe
across the board it's just really i
guess freedom is a word that comes to
mind it feels very free even the title
of the album being a horse i just
picture this wild horse like
running through a desert and being free
mirror mirror on the saddle here my
rhinestones rattle acting
not felt right for the first songs
i was struggling with the sequence i
kind of left it up to the boys i was so
inside of it at that point and had
lived with it taking breaks we worked on
this record for two years you know and i
lived with all these songs all my
records have led to a record like this
in a way because it's got kind of
everything on it
[Music]
it is a very important song on the
record number one is the first one we
wrote for this record and
really like with a vibe in mind
number two
i don't feel like i've gotten to do that
that much in my life like i tour i don't
get to be a tourist
[Music]
every time i hear that song and when b52
is coming i like
giggle with so much joy
when he's like it's a showboat baby i'm
like this is awesome how much more fun
can you have on tape
we went to a heart place in this song
like this
big bold love song
and we have references to roses in the
snow in it and
you know
hiding your bottle in your boot and like
all these cool
visuals
of like little details of this journey
into big love
and that track is just it's so in your
face and bold and we that one again we
worked on that one a lot we
from just an acoustic work tape with
john and luke playing to like making
sure we didn't make it too big or too
loud but to get our point across that
this is a huge love story
[Music]
this song gives me big time to seldom
feelings like
some like there's some sort of brooks
and dunn thread in it or 90s country
vibes and like the bars that i love to
sing in and grew up in it's all the
people that we see in the bars and that
we
[Music]
are when we're there with the girl in
the levi's dancing with all the cowboys
and
the ex-boyfriend that won't come here
because he knows i'm here like there's
all these
visuals in the one stirring up her
emotions in the ass with their
fingertips you just see all these people
because we've seen it because we sit in
dog bars that's where country music
lives and dies
changing ties and changing plans
i call it my pursuit of happiness
we kind of knew i think a pursuit of
happiness that the journey was complete
i think pursuit of happiness was when we
were all like
okay i think we've we've done it there's
a lot of chasing going on in this record
chasing down dreams chasing down lovers
chasing down old lives chasing down
money chasing down
happiness if i had to give
someone one song off the record
it'd just say
take a guess what this album's about
that song sums it up